oh I think we see they won with a
stranger things angle yeah and a
Confederate flag in the back of that
truck
don't tell me sticker don't shoot at me
see this is what Donald Trump and Ed
Gillespie mean by the well the lady a
little girl no jab should be thankful
she woke up in the United States if
she's waking up in a Muslim country Ruby
sweetie
time for your sex slavery not again
yesterday eight people were killed by a
terrorist running over pedestrians in
New York City with a truck so the
question of the day here
anyone can point out hypocrisy with the
media inconsistencies we want to go a
little bit deeper than that but I think
you'll notice how they handle different
scenarios comparing this with Vega
absolutely what do you think is a more
rational fear that of guns themselves
that of the the inanimate objects that
are that is a gun or that of Islam
itself distilling it a gun or the ideas
of Islam let us know below and by the
way if you're watching this on YouTube
you need to start hitting the belphin
notifications bookmarking this page or
join mug club because youtube is decided
you're no longer going to be notified of
our videos for YouTube yes so because I
think we know the answer this question
this by the way everywhere obviously
this happened the terrace attack and
you're not a lot of sit-ins in st.
Mark's Square to yell out a lot of work
bar yeah well nothing nothing cool has
ever preceded the phrase Allah Akbar
yeah no it's benign ii ok boring prayer
or someone's dying yeah so you're saying
we need a bane Allah ho Akbar and then a
matter of love to sing on ok the one
time they step up to defend free speech
all of a sudden and I'm going to be
consistent you shouldn't ban obviously
Allah Akbar I say find middle ground
just start decriminalizing be beards
signet a fan on Lord yeah I'm there yes
irony alert I get it
so this lets the only late-night host
who address the terror attack that night
was stephen colbert it appears a
terrorist has attacked innocent citizens
in lower manhattan in all of our hearts
all of our broken hearts go out to
everyone affected and to all those who
live and work in this great city
tomorrow and the next day new yorkers
will wake up to new dean
about what happened but tomorrow and the
next day New Yorkers will also wake up
and keep going because in an uncertain
world one thing is for sure
New Yorkers will never live in fear
never live in fear compare that to the
reactions and the fear-mongering after
the last mass shooting let's see maybe
I'm nuts but I would like to think we
can put politics aside agree that no
American citizen needs an m16 or ten of
them are there no steps we can take as a
nation to prevent gun violence or is
this just how it is and how it's going
to continue to be Congress is going to
vote on deregulating gun silences gun
violence is out of control how can we
make it quieter you want to make America
great again pass any kind of
common-sense gun control legislation
that the vast majority of Americans want
actually that's not true what you think
common-sense gun control me to get into
exactly what that is so before we get to
the comparison of Islam and in guns and
what's a more rational fear skepticism
home let's first go to their claims in
late night about gun control the stuff
that they push immediately after the
Vegas shooting Washington Post actually
fact-checked Marco Rubio's claim not
that long ago they said none of the
major shootings that have occurred in
this country over the last few months or
years and have outraged us would gun
laws have prevented them they would not
have tremendum even the leftist
Washington Post said yeah that's true it
would not have prevent it's really hard
for any luck just to really argue that
honestly it would not stop any of the
shootings no on the other hand of course
there are instances where armed citizens
might have changed the odds no I'm not
it's never guaranteed that if someone
has a gun they're going to stop some
kind of a mass shooting but we do know
that a lot of these attacks have
occurred where it maybe it could have
been equalizer yeah if people were
allowed to carry and no one did good
example would be Fort Hood no guns
allowed New York City carry laws are
impossible you contrast that with a
place like Tennessee where a guy with a
gun stuffed a mass shooting in a church
last month I'd never hear about that no
in Vegas Vegas as a gun state woman not
at a mass gathering no contents not at
all it's actually one of the few things
that Islamic terrorists in non-islamic
shooters share in common they
statistically seek scenarios where
people would not have guns readily
available to defend themselves but the
same shows that terrorists don't rely on
guns
the United States the OSU student drove
into a crowd and started stabbing people
in Europe you have teres running a truck
through a Christmas market in Berlin 12
dead 49 injured terrorists plotting two
people in the London Bridge killing six
dozens more injured Tara slammed avange
Pradesh abut Barcelona that was 14 I
think killing more than a hundred of
course he have Bastilla last year which
was 86 people died 458 injured didn't
require guns no it never does you know
it all seems they prefer vehicles in
knives yeah point well you can you can
do far more damage very quickly with a
car in the wrong direction it's good
yeah you think about we just you can do
it anywhere we talk about guns right we
want to stop somebody from having a clip
as they call it that's more than nine
rounds but you give a girl who's on
snapchat a Ford Explorer
well if the left's argument was just
consistent you would have heard Islam
and not terrorists it would have been
radical Islamic terrorism at the very
least right because they're quick to say
guns guns guns guns guns every time
something bad happens but this is just a
broad it's a terrorist attack so
important because you're talking about
an inanimate object versus you know
listen there are only so many ways to
say it okay I was sitting down and okay
we have another terrorist attack what
the deal with this in the story alright
how do we frame it this time listen
let's be really clear here okay
you have a religion Islam that advocates
for the punishment of homosexuals death
apostasy that women should be treated as
second-class citizens and of course so
should non-muslims and then you look at
Muslims across the entire world
homosexuality apostasy punishable by
death often herbs severe measures yeah
and women and non-muslims are
second-class citizens all the time I
think you get case in point that's it
people whatever what about the Muslim of
the United States I don't care about the
bosom of the United States okay come up
the entire the entire Muslim Islam
practicing wild is a crapple
I don't care about the small percentage
of it's like saying well listen what
about the Swedes the United States when
I talk about their social Nets out care
I don't care about the Suites
how about the Swedes in Sweden
just like you would tear about the few
Americans live in Nigeria no for young
people like that's not representative of
white Americans as a whole
yeah well what about the what about the
Americans over there in in Zimbabwe
health care system it's an exception not
the rule book says do this prophet says
do this every Muslim country does this
it says engage in terrorism Islamic
followers engage in terrorism and then
media says but there's no correlation
but both points you know there's not
there's nothing to fear in Islam for the
real threat Virginia's Latino victory
funds recent political ad let's watch
this where is it
what's the threat
they hit all the races there with the
kids dude that's good oh I think we see
they've won with a stranger things angle
yeah and a confederate flag on the back
of that truck
don't tell me sticker don't try that me
see is this what Donald Trump and Ed
Gillespie mean by the well the lady a
little girl in the head jab should be
thankful she welcomed the United States
if she's waking up in a Muslim country
be sweetie time for sex slavery not
again boy yesterday I think that you're
right so what is a more rational fear
okay well let's go back to guns guns are
used in self-defense by the way but far
more often the news nighted states to
kill from a hundred thousand of three
million cases each year according the
Census Bureau contrast Islamic terrorism
is the number one cause of terrorist
attacks in the United States in the past
decades and of course globally since
2001 over 3100 been killed by Islamist
contrast that with like you see in that
ad the evil Confederate flag wavers 106
the left that sleight of hand they do
often where they'll say well there have
only been X amount killed since and they
start counting September 12 it's it's
somebody say significally worth it
globally is Lama counts for an
overwhelming lighter for terrorist
groups Islamic groups alone seventy four
percent all deaths from terrorism okay
of course it's guns I mean I can see
from the evidence that it's guns we have
to deal with them not Islam it was crazy
to me where the left takes something
okay shooting and right away they go to
an inanimate object try and push ideas
they blame the gun to try and push
legislation that they themselves
acknowledge would not change anything so
inanimate object let's use that as the
boogeyman to push some ideas that we do
not know would ever make a difference on
the flip side when someone literally
Allahu Akbar what is that they're
yelling out their ideas they're saying
these are all of my values
I'm killing in the name of Islam it's
its stance from ideas they couldn't
possibly be more clear and the left says
well this isn't about ideas it's just
about some incident inanimate object
let's play mat push ideas someone
announces their ideas nothing to see
here
finally if you're not convinced or if
you don't know where I line up if
nothing else a firearm has never
actually said any of these things hey
did you enjoy this video here's the
thing you wrote you're here this is the
end of this oh we don't care because you
already watched it but if you really
didn't like it and you want to justify
it leave a comment below telling us why
you didn't like the video and if you
liked us let us know and subscribe to
the channel because that lets the
overlords at YouTube know that you know
what you're alright